je m'appelle marine j'ai 31 ans je suis
monteur aux mfp depuis 7 ans j'ai fait
deux ans de formation ici en bacs
professionnels
[Musique]
dont l'activité c'est de monter démonter
des
des compresseurs haute pression
du triple sept
[Musique]
à partir du 1er confinement on a
commencé à avoir beaucoup d'activité
partielle en gros on demande à nos
collègues de rester chez eux ils étaient
quand même payer mais on avait de moins
en moins de moteur sur le site et du
coup il n'ya pas du travail pour tout le
monde en plus c'était c'était un peu
long c'était c'est un moment où il n'y
avait pas grand monde dans l'atelier
nous on a l'habitude de voir pas mal de
monde parce qu'on est censé être 700 sur
le site et là c'était assez vide on
avait des périodes où on ne travaillez
pas du tout les périodes où certaines
personnes travaillent et enfin c'était
pas du tout la même ambiance de travail
c'était assez stressant au quotidien
puis les gens s'inquiétaient aussi pour
l'avenir du site quoi
la reprise je pense que ça a rassuré pas
mal de mes collègues qui ont fini par
dire bon bah ça va on n'a plus à
s'inquiéter pour notre avenir
oui ça fait plaisir de reprendre à un
rythme stable l'activité partielle elle
a pris fin il ya un mois et demi deux
mois mon vrai donc ça a quand même duré
très longtemps avant qu'on reprenne un
vrai rythme
c'est un vrai plaisir c'est
le fait d'avoir passé toutes ces années
gt gt à la réunion il ya une grosse
crise de l'emploi là bas donc d'être
arrivé ici trouver du travail facilement
en plus un travail qui est plutôt bien
rémunérés et qui est derrière est
agréable quand même c'est vraiment un
travail on est content de venir